bonsoir et bienvenue sur les routes du
tour de bretagne cycliste quatrième
étape déjà toujours sous le soleil une
étape extrêmement spectaculaire
aujourd'hui entre le rheu près de rennes
et ici-même fougères avec la célèbre la
fameuse et tant redoutée côte de la
pinterie il s'en est passé des choses ce
dimanche sur la route de fougères il ya
eu des codes des petit dru des
embouteillages et bien sûr des attaques
quatre coureurs ont passé une bonne
partie de l'étape à l'avant rousseau
sokol bamba relais spox ont longtemps
résisté au peloton un poteau et des
équipes professionnelles qui ont
aujourd'hui encore manqué de vigilance
en laissant s'échapper un équipier du
leader et un néerlandais
bien placé au général ensuite il a donc
fallu rouler à battre du travail et
laisser des forces dans cette bataille
al'approche de fougères les choses
sérieuses commencent les côtes sont de
plus en plus rude et l'écart commence à
baisser les échappées entre-temps tête
sur le circuit d'arrivée de fougères
mais ils n'ont plus que quelques
secondes d'avancé sur un peloton
désormais déchaîner la première échappée
reprise derniers kilomètres six coureurs
prennent le relais et il ya là par
exemple des habitués des attaques comme
le nantais tirer le brestois berthou
mathieu teychenne de l'équipe de l'armée
de terre et le jeune breton maxime bono
dans le dernier kilomètre c'est le
regroupement général rondot a tout de
même gardé quelques forces
j'y pensais depuis trois jours j'ai pas
trop fait des fleurs comme ont trois
jours pour 1
pour être bien posté à plat donc mais se
retrouver devant ça a failli faire je
vais peut être déçu parce qu'ils meurent
quand il reprend il était vraiment lancé
donc oui deuxième place pour maxime
renault sur ses terres il est seulement
battu par julian alaphilippe revenu sur
la fin j'avais rien à voir un peu
partout en général pas de changement aux
idoles est toujours un solide leader et
soyons clairs on voit mal désormais qui
peut battre l'autrichien demain la
direction le pays de loudéac 5e étape
sur 170 km entre saint thélo et le
quillio
[Musique]